this beautiful conference
and
uh this session is going to be proof
spruce proofs of all the different kinds
and lyron will be the first speaker so
without much ado please
hey everyone um i'm iran and i'm gonna
be presenting the talk on pcps and
instance compression from active from a
cryptographic lens this was a joint work
together with ron rothbomb from a
technion
so let's begin by talking about the
cryptographic lens
and what it essentially is is a way for
cryptographers to do the impossible
cryptographers often assume that the
adversary they're working against is
computationally bounded instead of the
classical unbounded adversary
and this allows them to construct
objects which are classically impossible
in this work we're going to use this
method to bypass impossibility results
for succinct pcps and instance
compression
so let's begin with a quick overview of
pcps which you already know so i'll do
it quickly
a probabilistically checkable proof is a
proof system for language l and np
um it consists of a lazy verifier wants
to know whether x belongs in l
so they contact approver the approver
writes a pcp proof and the verifier
being all lazy and all only reads a few
indices
from the proof and decides whether to
accept or reject
the requirements for pcps are first of
all completeness which states that if x
is true then we're interacting with the
honest prover the verifier accepts
and second of all is soundness when
x is false when the verifier interacts
with a malicious prover
but even against in an unbounded
malicious prover which is denoted by
these carry lightning bolts
for whichever proof this unbounded
prover writes the verifier rejects with
good probability
um all known pcps have proof length
which is polynomial both in the length
of the witness w and the instance x
and this can be problematic in some
cases and the example you should be
thinking of is sat where the length of
the proof or the assignment is poi
logarithmic in the length of the
instance
and
where the instance is very very long and
the witness is very short the proof ends
up being too long
and ideally we'd like there to be
succinct proofs or succinct pcps where
the length of the proof is polynomial in
the length of the witness and not the
much longer instance
but unfortunately foreign showed back in
2011 that succinct bcps for sat cannot
exist unless the polynomial hierarchy
collapses
but perhaps we can have something that
is very close and and here we use a
cryptographic perspective and conserve
probabilistically checkable arguments or
pcas defined by calling rouse back in
2009
a pca is a computational analog of a pcp
so what this means is instead of having
regular soundness or unconditional
soundness we have a computational
soundness against computationally
bounded adversaries
so if x is false
when interacting with a malicious prover
that previously had scary lightning
bolts to mean that it is unbounded here
we remove the lightning bolts
lymphocytes that the adversary is
computationally bounded
and when reading the proof written by
this computationally bounded adversary
the verifier rejects
so these are pcas
and a natural question is whether there
exists succinct pcas for sat and caleras
actually showed back in 2009 that
succinct pcas for sat do exist assuming
crypto
but there are two major caveats
the first caveat is that this
construction is designated verifier
meaning the approver only writes the
proof for one specific verifier no one
else can verify
and this is unlike with pcps where
everyone can verify a pcp proof
so this is the first the first caveat
and the second caveat is that the their
pca construction has super constant
query complexity and it's actually not
bad it's polygorithmic but it's not
quite as good as pcps which have
constant query complexity
and in our work we actually get rid of
both of these caveats
so what we do is in theorem one 1
we assume sub-exponential lwe and
standard cryptographic assumption
and for every bonded depth and
p-relation we show that there exists
publicly verifiable constant query
synced pcas
so what this means is your favorite np
relation has a succinct pca
which is publicly verifiable meaning
that everyone can verify it and thus
verification can be done using a
constant number of queries just like in
pcbs except that here the proof is much
shorter it is succinct comparable to
witness length
so an application of pcas
is in the field of harness of
approximation
this is usually attributed to pcps but
it can be interesting to know whether
the slider notion of the pca can suffice
when showing harness of approximation
and and actually on paper we show that
it does suffice we use pcas to re-prove
known hardness of approximation results
so what we do is
we show a proof sketch for the following
fact
and the search variant of maxsat is hard
to approximate
this was already known from pcps but we
showed that this is provable using the
slider tool of pcas
so now that we know the pcas can show
hardness of approximation an open
question that remains is whether they
can show new harness results and we
leave that open question for future work
so now we move on to the second point uh
about instance compression originally
defined by hernik and all back in 2010
and instance compression is the
following notion say you have a long
instance x with a short witness w like
before sat with long formulas and short
assignments
um instance compression is a polytime
function f which maps the instance x
into a shorter instance x prime
the length of x prime is polynomial in
the length of the witness w
so here we actually compress the
instance hence the name instance
compression
moreover
instance compression also requires that
x prime is true if and only if x is true
this means that there exists a witness w
prime for x prime if and only if there
exists a witness w for x
this notion has many applications but
unfortunately for now sentinelum showed
that instance compression for sat is
impossible assuming the polynomial
hierarchy doesn't collapse
um so once again we bypass this
impossibility result using
cryptography in our work we define
computational instance compression which
is a very similar notion in the sense
that it allows for compressing of long
instances down to witness length but
that there are a few differences
and the first difference is that we
require that if x is true then x prime
is true similar to before
and second of all we require that if x
is false then it is intractable to find
the witness w prime for x prime
note that it says intractable and not
impossible because even for false x's
there might exist a witness w prime for
x prime but we require that it'd be
intractable to find it within reasonable
time
and lastly and we require that there
also be a polytime function g
which allows you to map a witness w into
a witness w prime hence being able to
prove that the original x was true if
you had a witness for it
in theorem 2 we showed that assuming the
same cryptographic assumption namely
subexponential lwe
then for every bond the depth and p
relation there exists a
computational instance compression
scheme to set
um so once again this means that your
favorite mp relation is compressible
down to set
to conclude
in our work we assume standard
cryptography and for a large subclass of
np relations
we first of all show that there exists
succinct pcas which can be used to show
hardness of approximation results
second of all we show that there exists
computational instance compression and
thus we overcome the impossibility
results for succinct pcps and instance
compression thanks for listening
excellent uh any questions uh you could
post in a chat uh you can
i have a question
if we can make sure
your um your turn of statements you had
the
for every bonded depth amplitude what do
you mean by bonded depth here
um so these are relations that can be
verified by low depth circuits so log
space uniform and see
like
so
an np relation is uh can be verified
generally by a p circuit
but we only have a result for circuit
for relation that can be verified by log
space uniform and c circuit so i guess
this matters in your setting i mean in
general you can always make the verifier
like the 3c and f but in your setting
you you cannot because
you are decoupling i guess input length
from witness length
yes okay
thanks
sure
okay more questions comments or
actually
if i mean so what does this show will be
sharp this
limitation of the depth
is that the
what is this limitation of the burn
depths uh
come up what what technique uh
requires this assumption on the
amplitude as opposed to like the
eponymous size required
um it's derived from the snarks that we
use the proof systems that we use that
originally a gkr and the proof system
gkr has this limitation and they all
know okay
thanks
maybe we just add that it's entirely
possible that we could get rid of this
limitation using uh
no reason no reason why it should be
inherent
yep
right
thank you so much this is great so um
maybe uh
lauren thank you so much for great talk
if you don't mind stop and sharing and
guy
you're the next one
yeah yes hi can you hear me
yes excellent so guy goldberg is the
next speaker please
hi yes so i'm guy i'm a phd student at
the weizmann institute of science
and i'm going to talk today about the
joint work with guy rothblom
about the assembly-based proofs of
proximity
and
before i present the model we start in
this world
let's begin with the following problem
say that i have two strings and i want
to check if they are identical or far
from each other that is that i need to
change at least an excellent fraction of
the bits of one string to get to the
second string
and also let's assume that we need to
reject such a bad inputs only with high
probability say two things
so there is a very simple algorithm for
this problem
simply choose uniformly random and index
j from 1 to n
query y at index j queries edit
index j
check if they are equal or not and
repeat this simple test for enough tags
and so what we get is we call this
algorithm intestine
we get the tester with query complexity
the number of bits it needs to width
from the input
is about one over epsilon
and for this algorithm to work we really
need
to have the ability to query the input
at arbitrary locations of our choice
another model that of a input access
that we can consider
is a sample based access
it appears for example in machine
learning machine learning settings
so in this type of access
we get samples of the input each sample
is of the form i
xi so we get the location of the sample
and the value of the input at this
location
and the samples are distributed
uniformly random and they are
independent of each other
so now we can longer can no longer do
what we did before we cannot query
y and z at the same location
so the best algorithm we can
do for this problem
well it's basically basically just
draw samples at random wait until you're
lucky and find a
y and z at the same location
and test if it equals or not
and for a constant epsilon by a birthday
paradox argument
we need to have at least square root of
n samples
in order to to hit such a collision with
a high probability
so how can we somehow help this tester
and reduce the number of samples it need
to draw
one possibility is to give him the help
of a of approval
so in an interactive proximity we now
call the tester verifier
and we allow it to communicate with
untrusted profile
the prover is unlimited in its
computational complexity for now
and
and we also assume it is
it can read all of the input x so we
don't charge it for reading the input
and we as in the previous talk we need
completeness and soundness completeness
means that if x is in the input
if x is in the language then the product
can convince us to accept the input
and for sunless we relax the demand we
want that if x is epsilon far from the
language
we want that no prover will be able to
convince us to accept
except for a small probability of error
and
now the verifier can be can have query
access or several access to the input
and now we are also measuring the
communication complexity of the protocol
which is the total number of beats
exchanged between the parties
and we want
it to also be a subliminal
so to put our
work in context
we have the area of property testing
where we don't have approval
which is a wide field
and well studied
mostly when the tester has query access
to the input but also when the when it
has sample access
the recent line of work studies the
power of those ipps interactive proofs
of proximity
when the verifier has query access
and now in this new work we study
what
is the power and limitations of such
course of proximity
when the verifier is restricted to have
simple access to things
so
for the quality testing form before we
have a simple a single round protocol
and it works as follows
first the verifier draws a single sample
say that it was in index i
now it turns i modulu m to the power
which is like the relative index of this
sample
in the completeness case when y equals v
the prover sends to the verified single
bit
which equals to yj which is the same as
zj and the verifier checks that the
value it got from the provider equals to
the value of the center
in the sound case when y is epsilon 5
from z
then with probability of epsilon
yj is going to be
different than zj and what can the
prover do now
the point is that it doesn't know where
the sample of the verifier were
if it was in the y part or in the z pad
so the best it can do is to send a
random bit to the verifier and then with
probability half the verifier is going
to catch it
by repeating this a small protocol for
enough times
we get a protocol with good soundness
and the sample complexity is one of the
epsilon the communication complexity is
logarithmic and compare this to the
square root n lower bound we had
for a sample based tester that couldn't
use a problem
in the paper we generalized this
protocol and we show that if a language
has a query based tester
then it also has a sample based
interactive proof of proximity with good
parameters
but what if the language doesn't have a
query based tester
our main result is a reduction
and we show that if a language has a
query based interactive proximity
uh with some assumptions from from this
proof system
that it also has a sample-based
interactive proof of proximity
and the overheads in terms of query
sample complexity and communication
complexity is
not so bad
and why
this reduction is useful
because we know
of rich families of languages
that all of which has a
query based interactive proof of
proximity
and
so now we can apply this reduction on
those known families
to show that they also have sample based
interactive groups of proximities
and this might be a bit surprising
because as we saw with the quality
testing
sample-based testers are much restricted
much more restricted compared to
queerbase testers
so for tesla we lose power when we
go to sample access
and here in some sense
those models can be as powerful
with
some disclaimers
okay so
what we do now with this reduction
we get the following two results
the first one is that every language
with which is computable
in a low depth circuit
is the sub linear sample-based
interactive proximity
and the second result
is that every language which is
computable in polynomial time and bowed
and bounded polynomial space also have
has a sample-based interactive proof of
proximity with again sub uh sub linear
sample and communication complexities
and i know that i'll note that
those protocols are private coins and
that they are interactive so the
verifier needs to talk with that with
the problem
another two results which i will end
with them
are they lower bounce for equality
testing
and the first one
is
regarding a non-interactive proof
systems
where the prover sends a single message
to the verifier like a proof
and
and we show for the cell bank
and the second lower bound is for public
coins in the proof systems
where the verifier is restricted to send
only random bits to the folder during
the protocol
and you can see the full video
to see a proof sketch for the main
reduction we show in the paper
okay thank you
wonderful
thank you so much any questions
you could uh
either yeah i can see the chat before uh
unmute up to you
so actually i i have a very naive
question i was wondering if your results
imply something for
a learning um
kind of sample based learning versus
membership query based learning because
there is a similar kind of
so
usually when you talk about learning
you're interested in liking beating the
vc dimension
and not in the size of the support of
your distribution
[Music]
so here we don't show anything like
which is specifically for the vc
dimension and how to study
with less samples than than you need to
in the general case uh so here it's like
generic
uh
construction for any language
thank you
yeah this is really cool
okay
uh are you here
please yeah
thank you
all right uh can you guys see this
uh it's not full screen yet but
yeah
okay now this yeah
actually
there we go
all right um yeah uh thanks for coming
to my talk uh this is joint work with
tony and robert
um
and uh you're gonna see some extremely
deep proofs
um yeah so recently
um
several works have exhibited kind of a
new type of trade-off uh mostly improved
complexity
um this is known as a supercritical
trade-off um it's where one when you
restrict one parameter like one resource
another one is pushed beyond the worst
case
um yes this has been seen primarily in
proof complexity actually i think the
only examples i know of are improve
complexity um
so first beanbeck napoleotzo showed a
supercritical trade-off between size and
space for uh resolution
uh following up on this uh raspberrov
showed like an extremely strong type of
critical trade-off um he showed that for
the tree-like resolution group system if
you restrict the width
then the size of these proofs blows up
to be doubly exponential like 2 to the 2
to the n
and then following this a bunch of other
uh works showed various trade-offs
mostly between uh resources such as
width and size
uh for proof systems and um space
okay so in this work we give the first
supercritical tradeoff between two very
natural
parameters of proofs
uh the size and the depth
and we do this for uh several proof
systems so resolution kdnf resolution
and cutting plans
okay so i'll define what very roughly
what a proof system is or what you
should think of one as and also what
that is
so a proof system is a is a method for
producing proofs um that a given cnf
formula is unsatisfiable
uh so you start with a cnf formula and
we're going to think of it as like a set
of clauses
um and you derive new lines from old
ones using uh
a set of sound inference rules
so the standard example is the
resolution rule you take two clauses
with complementary literals and you
derive their disjunction canceling out
that complementary letter rule
so you can take these two clauses and
derive x3 for example
and the goal is to derive the trivially
false formula
and because these rules are sound you
know if you can derive the trivially
false formula then this is a proof that
the initial formula had no
uh satisfying assignments so we can go
ahead and do this resolve these two
clauses and
try out the empty clause
okay and this is the resolution curve
system
and the two parameters we're going to be
interested in here is size which is
roughly the number of inferences in the
proof in this case it's seven
um you need the initial clauses plus the
three inferences you made
and the depth which is the longest root
to leaf path in the proof
okay
so size is pretty natural but depth is
somewhat less studied
however there's a good analogy between
circuit complexity so just like how in
circuit complexity depth sort of
models parallelism it's the same in
proof complexity
uh so proof's cap proof depth captures a
notion of parallelism
um this is pretty natural because a lot
of proof systems model practical
algorithms
so the resolution-improved system
captures the complexity of modern
algorithms for set and cutting planes
captures
classical integer programming algorithms
then lower balance on size imply lower
bounce of runtime and lower rounds of
depth roughly lower bound
parallelizability
sorry
um
okay and
in all proof systems that we are going
to consider um
depth is at most n
um one second let me
try to make it
there we go hopefully that's better
um
yeah okay so in all the proof systems we
consider depth is the most n however
these depth and proofs may have
exponential size
um so in this work yeah we prove a
supercritical trade-off between size and
depth um
so
roughly um for any of the proof systems
resolution kdnf resolution or cutting
planes we show that there's a cnf
formula
on n variables
um such that it has polynomial size
proofs however any sub-exponential size
proof must have polynomial depth where
this polynomial is greater than n so
above worst case and our trade-off is
smooth so we we can ramp this up
um we can show that there's also a
formula which has weekly exponential
size proofs however any sub-exponential
size proof must have weekly exponential
depth
and very formally
uh our trade-off is as follows i'll
state it for resolution the trade-offs
for cutting planes and pdnf resolution
are basically the same the parameters
change a little bit which makes it
annoying to state like the general
theorem
um but yeah so if we let epsilon be some
constant and c be a real value parameter
that will control our trade-off then
there's a cnf formula which has proofs
of size n to the c
roughly uh however any
sub-exponential size proof um
has to have the following trade-off
between depth and size
so the depth times log of the size has
to be about uh n to the c
so instantiating c gives us the
trade-offs that you saw in the previous
two slides
okay um and the very i'm going to sketch
a very rough idea of the proof
um it's this hardness condensation
technique from raspberrov um
so basically what we're going to do is
we're going to start with a cmf formula
on capital lend many variables which has
small size proofs but requires large
depth so
these should be capital ns rather than
little ends
um
yes you should think of this as
polynomial in capital n being the size
and requiring
capital and
depth then we're going to find a way to
compress the number of variables while
maintaining that both a and b hold
so we compress the little n
and the upshot is that the new formula
that we get f prime
is still going to require capital n
capital and depth
uh but only has little and many many
variables so we get a supercritical
depth lower bound for small size proofs
um so how is compression done
we use lifting theorem
so if you're familiar with lifting
theorems you take a formula you compose
you replace each variable by a gadget of
new variables so x1 to xn are vectors of
new variables
but our lifting theorem has a bit of a
twist
these vectors of variables are no longer
disjoint sets so they overlap and this
overlap allows us to reduce the total
number of variables
um yeah so if you here's here's a little
picture if you think of the z variables
as the original variables there's
capital n many of them
um
the x variables as being the new
variables
uh and then the gadget g is yeah going
to be defined on uh
by uh replacing each z variable
with
um some x variables from the pool
effects variables and they're indicated
by the arrows so for example z1 is
replaced by x1
and x3 the gadget applied to those
variables
so that's very roughly how the how the
proof goes
and finally some open problems um
obvious ones like can you get super
critical sized up trails for other proof
systems such as resilient or stabbing
planes
um
and can you get super critical sidestep
tradeoffs from monotone circuits and in
the extended version of this talk
i give a few other open problems but
they need a bit of motivation they're
they're basically approaches to getting
this monotone circuit trade off
all right thanks
thank you so much excellent any
questions
so uh
just a quick question so in your proofs
um
is there some reason why
uh say wrestling seems harder to do than
the one that you did or do you think you
could just push the techniques that you
have
or does it require something
um for for the proof systems that we get
lower bounds we already know nice
lifting theorems and we basically take
advantage of those
uh for resolution it's not so clear
um
i'm not an expert on the state of the
art of resolum but i think
so resolutin f2 we definitely don't have
lower bounds on like size lower bounds
um
and
in some other cases i think over the
reels we do have lower bounds i'm not so
sure there
i'm nice that's that's really that's
extremely deep
[Laughter]
okay thank you so much if no more
questions stefan i think you're the next
one
uh yeah
yeah please
okay is uh is my presentation visible
uh it's not full page but it's visible
okay that's better
okay
um all right so let's get started sorry
everyone i'm stefan i'm a phd student at
mcgill and uh in this talk i'll be
talking about some algebraic proofs and
algorithms this is a joint work with
mika goose noah fleming and robert
robert
so let's start off with some background
on extension complexity so here we have
sort of the classical picture of this
concept where you have a lower
dimensional polytope p and it possibly
has many different defining facets and
what we would like is a higher
dimensional polytope a p prime uh with
many fewer uh defining facets which
projects down to the original polytope p
so this was originally thought up in
1988 by yanukakis and the reason why
this is useful is that it can
drastically speed up linear programming
so rather than optimize over p you can
optimize over p prime and project
downwards and this is also a useful
technique for giving lower bounds on
your program if you can show that
there's no small higher dimensional
polytope so let's give some formal
definitions here and rather than just
for a single poly type we'll work for a
pair of polytopes p and q so p will be
an inner polytope and q will be an outer
polytope and we call an extended
formulation k of this pair
to be a polytope
in higher dimensions that when projected
downward it contains the inner polytope
and is contained by the outer polytope q
so we can define extension complexity as
the smallest extended formulation in
essence that contains p and is contained
by q
uh so we minimize over all the extended
formulations and we count the number of
facets
so this minimization on its own is kind
of hard to work with so we'd like a more
combinatorial representation and in
yannick cox's original paper defining
this topic
he showed this beautiful factorization
theorem where if you have this easily
definable matrix called the slack matrix
representing distances between vertices
of p and facets of q
the non-negative rank of this matrix is
equivalent to the extension complexity
of this pair
so our goal will be to use well to
understand extension complexity as sort
of a circuit model for computing boolean
functions and yanukakis sort of
preliminary preliminarily did this in
his paper where he showed that you can
convert circuit gates to inequalities
uh so let's see how this works so if we
have a boolean function f we can define
a separating polytope p of f uh so the
definition here is p will contain the
convex hall of the ones of f and it will
have empty intersection uh with the
zeros of f so you can imagine if we want
to compute f if we have a separating
polytope all we need to know is if if
the input is inside the separating
polytoke uh great um and if not then it
must be a zero
here's just a picture sort of
illustrating this where uh p is
containing the convex hall and has empty
intersection with these zeros and
there's also a monotone version of a
separating polytope but there's some
technicalities there uh so i won't give
its full definition
all right so let's actually formalize
the computational model and so we want
to utilize extension complexity which
means we need an a pair of an inner and
outer polytope the inner poly type will
be the convex hall of the ones and we'll
need an outer polytope
uh so here we give one uh we can use
what we call the cartridge vegas
inequalities
so we define an inequality for every
zero of the function f so y is a zero
and on the left hand side we have
hamming distance uh so this sum over
indices of x i by one minus y plus one
minus x side by y i
um we say this is at least one and the
idea here is that any one of your
function is has to have hemi distance at
least one uh with any zero
and here uh below you have pictorially
uh what's going on where we have the
convicts all the ones and these
inequalities are flushed right up
against it
uh there's also a monotone version of
this which is uh basically the same
and in general since all we want is a
separating polytoke between the ones and
the zeros instead of just having a one
you can have an epsilon so epsilon
greater than zero and less than or equal
to one and this
allows a bit more space
so if we show side by side q of one and
q of epsilon q of one is right up
against uh the inner polytope whereas q
of epsilon allows more breathing room so
you can imagine if you're looking for uh
extension complexity of a separating
polytope it might be much smaller with
qf-epsilon
uh so we can actually define complexity
measures uh using these so on the
left-hand side we have step one and
monotone step one
and on the right hand side we have
separation complexity and monotone
separation complexity where we're
minimizing overall uh positive epsilon
of this non-negative rank
and so it looks esoteric however pablo
rubes showed that these are actually
quite natural
step one lower bounds formula size and
separation complexity lower bounds
circuit size likewise monotone
separation complexity lower bounds
monotone circuit size
uh and just as a reminder by janakakis's
factorization theorem another way to
rewrite this uh separation complexity is
just the minimization over these
epsilons uh the extension complexity of
the pair the convex hall the ones and qf
epsilon
so what we would like to do is take this
analysis and apply it to query
complexity and proof complexity
as we'll hop right into semi-algebraic
proofs now and so we start with conical
hunter degree and all this is is a
certificate that your boolean function
is not negative
and we do this by factorizing it into a
conic sum of conjunctions we call juntas
so a junta is just a product of
variables
where uh some of them are uh multiplied
positively and the others are uh in a
sense negated with a one minus so you
can really just think of these as
conjunctions polynomial versions of
conjunctions and we see below as an
example if you have the conjunction x1
and not x2 and x3 and x4
this is converted into multiplying uh x1
x3 x4 as well as 1 minus x2 since x2 is
the only negated variable
so conical junta is just a conical sum
of hundes so all the coefficients are
going to be at least zero
and we can define conical hunter degree
as just the minimal degree d where you
can represent your boolean function as a
congo hunter
uh so for extension complexity uh we had
this slack matrix um encapsulating
extension complexity um and this matrix
is non-negative and when you factorize
the slack matrix into these uh
a sum of non-negative franklin matrices
this is in essence a proof of its
non-negativity and so we do the exact
same here thing here for a specific
polynomial uh and we're going to show
that it is non-negative by factoring in
juventus
so what is this certain polynomial it's
the violations uh polynomial uh so if we
have an unsatisfiable cnfc then we can
define uh the vial of c as just the sum
of the negated clauses and so on
on an explicit input this counts the
number of violated clauses and of course
since we assume that c is unsatisfiable
this means that the number of violations
is always at least one
so to prove that c is unsatisfiable if
all you need to do is show that a vial
minus 1
is
at least 0 or just for any epsilon
between 0 and 1 showing that vial minus
epsilon is greater than 0.
uh so if we take that same
representation we saw with separation
complexity doing this minimization um of
conical hunter degree of vial minus
epsilon uh perhaps this is interesting
and our first result um in this work is
that this actually equals something very
natural it is equivalent to shirali
adam's degree
so what is shirali adams well it's
another proof system so we're trying to
verify that a cnf is unsatisfiable um
and this is the the proof system that
corresponds with using linear
programming uh for approximation
algorithms so it's a very natural proof
system to study
and so it's also a generalization of
conical hunter degree so below we have
an example of what australian's
refutation is on the right-hand side we
have minus one so negative and on the
left-hand side we have um something that
is non-negative giving a contradiction
and so likewise with a conical hunter
degree shirley adams degree is just the
minimum degree d we need to give a
shirley adams refutation of c and if
you'd like to see more uh in general
first semi algebraic proof systems i
recommend seeing noah's book on the
topic
so
back to our results uh so we we first
showed that this minimization is
equivalent to shirley adams degree so
it's natural to ask um well clearly this
simulates conical hunter degree uh but
what about the reverse and so we answer
this negatively uh where we show that
there is a family of cnfs in resolution
uh that it can be done easily that
conical hunter degree requires large
degree in fact linear and so this is uh
known as the iteration problem
uh and we are able to use uh uh kothari
mecca ragaventra's lifting theorem uh
that lifts uh conical hunter degree to
not negative rank and we're able to
translate this result to circuits uh so
in fact we're able to separate monotone
circuit complexity uh from mcef1
so here is just a full picture of all of
our results
so on the left hand side we have
proofland where we separate resolution
uh from conical hunter degree and on the
right hand side we have the lifted
version
um and additionally we so we show
feasible interpolation which i won't
fully get into but it's it's just
showing that you can take a proof and
convert it into a computation uh
verifying unsatisfiability and we show
that monotone separation complexity uh
feasibly interpolates uh shiraeli atm's
degree
um and so in some upcoming work we've
also noted that a lot of these arguments
also work for sums of squares
all right so uh thank you for listening
uh be happy to hear any questions you
guys have
thank you so much this is really cool
any questions any comments
so uh
one question so the conical hunter
degree corresponds to shirali adams
right
do you have similar kind of
characterization you mentioned sos
maybe for other systems kind of going
back from the proof systems to your
characterizations well so uh the only
other one we've considered is is uh sum
of squares um it it might be interesting
to look at other uh systems as well but
um
yeah
that's not something that we've
considered
really nice thank you
anybody else questions comments
okay then
if you don't mind stop stop and sharing
and uh
and please the floor is all yours
all right you can see me hear me
perfect
alrighty uh thanks for sticking around
to the last talk of the session uh my
name is ian i'm going to talk a little
bit about lifting theorems and
combinatorial sunflowers
and uh just want to shout out my
co-authors on the west coast there's
raghu mecca japan chang and shahar
lovett and then on this side we've got
uh tony potassi who is currently at
columbia
so i'm going to be talking today about
the interplay between two computation
models decision trees and communication
complexity
and i'm going to quickly define them and
show why i think decision trees are weak
and communication complexity is strong
so decision trees you've probably seen
before
uh you can think of them as a rooted
binary tree where at every internal node
you have a
the valley a label of an input variable
and
the two edges coming off of the node are
going to be labeled zero and one and the
idea is just that you ask what the value
of that input variable is and you go
down the corresponding edge until you
reach a leaf at which point you announce
the value of the function
so this is a non-uniform model in the
sense that once you've read all of the
variables you know exactly what the
value of the function is
and so
the depth of this tree is at most n and
we're going to call the depth of this
tree the decision tree complexity and
it's weak because for some very basic
functions such as the or function you
can't do any better than n really so
it's not too hard to come up with simple
functions that are maximally hard for
decision trees
on the other hand in communication
complexity we're going to have two sets
of variables we're going to have some x
variables and some y variables
and the x variables are going to be
given to one player named alice and the
y variables to the other player named
bob
and they're going to be computationally
unbounded there's no restrictions on
what they can compute
but because they only have half of the
input each they have to communicate
somehow to solve the function
and
we're going to measure communication
complexity by the number of rounds it
takes uh and the number of bits they're
going to have to send in the worst case
to compute the function
and again we can look at this as a tree
where each internal node is going to be
now an arbitrary function over one half
of the variables to the other either x
or y and again they're just going to
output a bit and you're going to follow
accordingly so this keeps track of the
transcripts thus far
and the depth here again is at most
say n where n is the smaller side
because one of the players can just send
their whole input
but uh for simple functions
for many simple functions this is of
course much less than n and in fact it
captures some much more difficult
notions such as uh formula depth so this
is a very strong model of computation
and the reason uh we were talking about
these two models that seem quite
different
is that uh lifting which noaa alluded to
in this talk earlier is going to be a
generic strategy for turning lower
bounds in the decision tree world which
are easy to come by
into lower bounds in the communication
world which is something we uh we care a
lot about and is a much harder task
and it's going to be generic in the
sense of for any function that's hard
for decision trees we're going to cook
up a function that's hard for
communication
and specifically it'll be this function
so we're going to take the original
one-party function f and replace each
variable zi
with an inner function which we call the
gadget g applied to some fresh set of
variables x i and y i which are split in
the natural way between alice and bob
the idea is if we just gave alice and
bob half the z variables each they could
uh
express some more complicated relations
over all the variables that they've got
whereas if we split the value of each
variable up between them
the hope is that they have to do a lot
of communication to even learn about
what these zi variables are and
so when if we keep track of which
variables they're communicating a lot
about it's like they're doing a decision
tree essentially
uh and to formalize this intuition
uh here's going to be our inner function
so the inner function is called the the
index gadget
it's parameterized by some number m
and alice is going to get log n bits
which you can think of as a number from
1 to m and bob will get
m bits which we think of as an array of
length m and then the index gadget is
simply the value in bob's array pointed
to by alice's element
and this is pretty general in the sense
of you can think of alice as getting an
input to a function and bob is holding
the truth table to it so this captures a
pretty natural uh pretty naturally
captures the kinds of inner functions
we'd want to compute
and it turns out with this
index gadget you can actually prove the
the lifting theorem that you want so
this is kind of the original lifting
theorem and it's been uh refined and
improved upon many times
but originally it was due to rosin
mckenzie in the late 90s what they show
is that as long as you pick m large
enough some large polynomial in n you
can get that the communication
complexity of this composed function is
the decision tree complexity of the
original unlifted function times
this log m overhead to compute the index
gadget
so just to see where that's coming from
let's see the easy direction if you've
got a decision tree for f
alice and bob can start at the root and
anytime they need to query a variable
say zi
alice is going to send her entire value
x i log out log n bits and then bob will
just send back the answer to the index
gadget and then they go down the
appropriate edge of the decision tree
and they keep going
and what we show in our paper uh not
today you'll probably have to watch the
full talk for the details uh is that the
other direction also holds
so just to say what we're contributing
in this work we developed a different
technique for proving one of the central
lemmas in this uh lifting result uh
using combinatorial sunflowers and the
advantage is that it actually works for
a very uh very broadly for many of the
lifting theorems that have been proven
since that original uh results of rosin
mckenzie
it uh replaces they all use different
framing and then they've got a slightly
different central lemma that are proved
in different ways and we unify these all
under one central lemma that's proved
one way
and it not only is it proved one way but
it's proved very very simply it's
just uh an application of a lemma from
combinatorics plus
maybe a quarter to a half a page of
framing so this really eliminates a lot
of the uh technical challenge involved
in previous lifting proofs
and it also comes with it a uh a
quantitative improvement which is that
we can improve on the value of m that uh
works for the lifting theorem so the
larger we make m the worse our lower
bounds we get out of this lifting result
and so
improving m down to say a constant is
the holy grail of lifting theorems
that's not an overused term
and what we do is we improve from all
the previous numbers which ranged from
say n squared all the way up to n to the
256
uh we reduce the all to n to the one
plus epsilon for any epsilon you pick
and that uh
it's uh comes with the possibility of
future improvement which is that if you
improve this sunflower lemma you get
immediately smaller gadgets we've
removed the dependence on m from
everywhere else in the proof
okay so i don't have a lot of time but i
just want to say a couple of things
about how the proof works the whole idea
is that our gadget is supposed to be
obfuscating the variables so we want to
say that the important coordinates are
the ones where alice and bob are
communicating a lot of information about
them
and what we hope from the index gadget
is that for any variables where they
haven't sent a lot of information they
know basically nothing about the value
of the actual zi variable computed by
the index gadget
uh the way we track how they're actually
how much they've actually talked about a
coordinate is by min entropy so if you
have some set of possible
from bob's perspective there's some
possible set of values that alice could
be holding
determined by the protocol thus far
and we look at the minimum entropy if
you restrict to any of the particular
coordinate ci of the possibilities
left for alice's input on those
coordinates
and this has the nice property that it's
log n if everything's uniform and uh
zero if it's not and it decreases by at
most one every time they send a bit
which means that
uh after it will take them something
like log m rounds before the min entropy
drops by a constant factor at which
point whichever coordinate caused the
min entropy to drop below this threshold
we can query that in our decision tree
and that we can be reasonably sure
that's an important coordinate
and then where sunflowers come in is the
opposite side which is that if you uh
look at all the coordinates that haven't
been queried in the decision tree as
long as the min entropy is high all
possibilities are still available for
the index gadget
so i can't go through the connection
today i uh would suggest taking a look
at the paper or at the full talk i just
want to note that this actually closes
off a loop which was established by
earlier work which showed that if you
could improve uh lifting theorems query
to communication lifting you can
actually get better results in
combinatorics for the sunflower lemma
and now again we've shown that better
sunflowers improve your lifting so i
think it would be nice to flush out this
connection more and see how deep
it runs
and of course it would be good to keep
improving on the size of the
uh gadget that we need all the way down
to order one would be fantastic these
can all be achieved by various
combinatorial results and we talk about
it a little bit in the paper
and of course it'd be nice to get this
to work for gadgets but other gadgets
that we care about like inner product
uh so that's basically it thanks
thank you so much this is really cool
so any questions comments
better sunflowers
i have questioning for me uh
easy
is your sunflower technique um
for the
index gadget or could you work for other
gadgets like ip so i just i don't have a
sense like how much
sunflowers have through with indexing as
opposed to other things
for the time being it is specialized for
the index gadget
but uh we've been thinking about how it
might be applicable to something like
inner product again index gadgets very
general in the sense of you can look at
uh the the larger side as a truth table
and you're applying sunflowers when you
apply the sunflower lemon we're applying
some randomized one where we think about
a random set over a universe which is
like a random input to uh bob's side
once you go to like the inner product
gadget now it's not uniform over all
possible sets they're like uh very
controlled and so you have to come up
with uh
lemon lemons that are more specific for
different distributions
uh if you know anything about
approximate sunflowers i guess the idea
is like approximate sunflower lemon
under different uh distributions
it's not out of the realm of possibility
though
and so just a quick follow-up
is your lifting also work for like
randomized uh
bbt is another thing we've been thinking
a lot about uh there the parameters that
we get from our main lemma are just
slightly off in terms of the loss that
you incur uh we have like a
multiplicative loss and bpp requires an
additive loss
but uh again that's something we've been
working on quite a bit so i'll get back
to you if we can think of anything
all right thanks
more questions comments
if
to ian or maybe to other speakers
thank you very much everybody it was
fantastic sessions so so many cool
things
and uh i guess
we are well
on time we even have a couple of minutes
to still think around here before the
next session starts so thank you so much
for for this this is wonderful
you